is your dad still with us no he died uh
when I was in
prison he came to see me uh yeah he came
to see me two or three times when is the
first time he found out that you were
doing fraud the first time I got in
trouble when you got the pro because I
had you know I had to kind of
explain that you know like something's
happening I didn't want him to hear from
anybody else so you so you talk to him
directly about
it super
disappointed did he ever tell you he
loves you after that so I after I got
the 26 years and the government decided
they weren't going to Indi
anybody and I really was like wow this
is it like you're done he came to see me
but just by himself and I remember
he I remember when he came to see
me I you know he was by he was by
himself like he never came by himself so
I remember
thinking my mom something happened to my
mom and I as soon as I walked in you
know he walked and I what I go where's
mom and he goes oh no she's fine she's
fine and he sat down with me and he said
uh and I he said uh how how are you
doing I was like I'm good and he was
just
like hey you know he was getting sick he
was getting older so you know we talked
for a little
bit uh just about the situation and I
was like yeah he's like what are you
going to do and I was like you know
there's nothing I can do like everybody
I've called multiple attorneys I've
talked to people there's nothing I can
do and he was like um you know we you're
going to figure it out you know he
goes
um he said you're
clever and you're smart and you're gonna
you're not going to do all of that time
and I was like I'm
done it's
over I'm going to get out of here when
I'm 60 if I behave myself and if I don't
I'll be
64 and he was like that's not going to
happen and
uh so he said uh
I think that was the first time he you
know I knew he was proud of me when I
was making money but he never said it
you know you got the look like he was
like
impressed but we were sitting
there and he said I remember he said cuz
it's the only time I can ever remember
him saying he was proud of me and I
remember he said you're going to figure
this out he said I I'm not proud of
where you ended
up but you've done amazing things you
know he said I wish you'd use your
talents for something different but
you've done things that I could have
never done and you've LED an amazing
adventurous life and I'm proud of
you and that you know I wish he could
see you
now my mom uh my mom saw me my mom's
funny cuz my mom came to see me my mom's
a gangster
MH my mom came to see me every two weeks
for 13 years she missed about a month
and a half when she had a
stroke and ended up in a wheelchair and
then she came in the wheelchair and she
would make my brother bring bring her my
brother and sister would be like Mom are
you sure you want to go like you know it
it's it's so hard to it's it's such a
long drive and you get so tired well
I'll sleep in the
car I know but you know uh then you we
have to wait in that that lot Li the the
you know in that um the waiting area you
know forever and it takes forever well
I'm in the wheelchair so I'm
fine well I know but it's such a pain to
get in and out and then in and out she
was like she was I'm going to see my son
and you're taking
me she uh yeah so I I so she yeah she
was uh she was something else and and uh
I always say you
know like if if I had to
say you know I don't think about all the
things I did to get out like I know you
know there's all these guys that are you
know like you know oh I wouldn't have
done that I'd have been a standup guy
and I'd have been well good for
you bro I wanted to get out I wanted out
and
the icing on the cake of me getting
out and I I would have cut every
motherfucker's head in that prison
off I was able to get
out just in time to
spend the
last year and a half of my mother's life
with
her I saw her two or three times a week
took her to dinner once a
week was able to W go on walks with her
in her wheelchair I was sitting right
next to her when she had her final
stroke
I held her
hand when she took her last
breath so if I have to be called a
snitch the rest of my life I don't give
a
fck like I I may not deserve more but
she deserve
more